welcome to this video playing women
international master just from Brazil
1799 Juliana salmeterol never how ok
playing b6 the own defense and now we
have transposed to a Sicilian type of
structure which does not really fit well
with my intention to play just my main
line stuff but ok after b6 you view are
provoked and need to react so we got to
the salient and will be 6 is normally a
bit slow for the Sicilian let's see how
to develop you know maybe yeah just just
keep it simple Bishop d3 and castles
short ok she's going for b5 after all
just with the tempo down ok I don't f
for this may be Bishop c5 not sure that
I want that so maybe get out of this
okay Queen f3 maybe and rookie one yeah
this so-called third-ranked setup is not
bad quick and also sometimes be used on
g3 or h3 so just go in here now maybe
that irritates black if black castles
there's a5 here I thought this would be
dangerous really okay let's not spend
ages on that because after the capture
96 and the recapture both bishops get
active and there's bishop age six for
example should be a should be dangerous
really young Queen g4l g6 or to age
three yeah but this must be okay ready
now Bishop age 60 my guesses cannot be
bad that's very good luck takes f7 and
it's very close to working maybe it is
working
look f7 King takes look f1 check yeah
maybe just night back to f6 and possible
but I can take this at least very
dangerous rook takes King takes rook as
one check pingy aid Queenie 6
threatening look fa checkmate this is
very strong okay rook takes on have sand
King district everyone checking g8 can
take a 6 he goes she goes to a jade and
then that's that's it but after the
checking Jedi have Bishop takes g6 which
threatens Bishop takes h5 this threatens
oh come on I think this is working if
it's not working well I've lost many
more wacky games why not try that one
the thing is what I didn't calculate is
some song yeah all kinds of yet
intermediate moves Bishop g2 check this
kind of stuff sack and maybe there's
something like that working king yet
yeah sure jus 6 not of not working
unfortunately okay 26 is their Bishop g2
my king takes and there is no Queen
check this is this is quite okay and
King g8 Bishop g6 that looks devastating
rename yeah come on this is working
don't tell me like as a defense to that
if black and I'll place a piece back and
this is a possibility of course i have
to i can take later night f slack resign
designs wow that's a shame I'm not sure
at all that this is this is on yeah
black black is not losing here
she wants to impress maybe he and
unjustly sell but let's get to get
through the lines this I think is easy
now Queenie six and it's plus 40
according to the comp + 40 not a mate
funny enough yeah okay well plus 40 s
and now how to take that and now it
finds a mate make it seven okay this is
not on this move Bishop g6 I think
should work our queen e six is also
winning called Queenie six winning let's
look at this first and now that one you
have intending this look sec and wins
one point is that this is also wind for
black Wow air for white I'm sorry okay
this wasn't my plan I was intending to
take here I hope this wins as well it
doesn't okay ah quin take c5 can we take
c5 as a defense I have I mean and it
looks it looks very very dangerous for
black but it's the computer should
really evaluate this perfectly at least
was some time shangli gives this and set
some black is slightly better which is a
very funny way to assess the standard
position at least there's no made so the
sir was was the best i was was a decent
way to play and the computer wants to
play this one after which I thought I
just take and have compensation which is
maybe too optimistic well the computer
also gives me gives me an edge but it's
not easy especially considering the
moose let's follow I was just I mean
playing it honor let's let's try that to
be her base
Queenie 5 and now a computer wants to
play night d 1 which is a move I
probably never would have played to f2
to g4 and the long run yeah the
compensation is somewhat based on the
fact that this night is bad on age 5 I
see that there is something but I'm
surprised that the computer actually
gives me a slight advantage here it's a
bit surprising yeah what residing was
clearly a premature okay thanks for
watching